auf der suche nach würdigen nachfolger
für power videos wie ich habe
feldwerbung aufgehängt oder ich habe
vermelden ein museum gehängt ist mir die
idee gekommen dass ich fett produkte in
einen fake laden nicht in ein fake laut
dass ich weg produkte in einen laden
schmuggeln möchte keinen laden eignet
sich dafür besser als ikea denn ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass da irgend
jemanden überblick hat also bin ich zu
ihr gefahren habe mir die produkte
angeschaut und habe mir angeschaut wie
die gelabelt sind dann habe ich einst
der labels geklappt habe ich einst der
labels in meinem rucksack wieder
gefunden als ich zu hause war habe das
abfotografiert in photoshop eingefügt
und meine eigene interpretation eines
produkts mit einfließen lassen dann
brauche ich noch ein produkt irgendwas
was einfach leicht zu transportieren ist
also habe ich ein beistelltisch aus
meinem zimmer mitgenommen und bin zu
ikea gefahren vor ort habe ich das label
dann noch zugeschnitten in eine
originale klarsichtfolie von ikea
gepackt und wir waren bereit wieder
großes zu vollführen und dieses produkt
in die kehre zu spüren war eine sache
noch bevor es losgeht ich habe mir ein
riesiges ziel gesetzt ich möchte dieses
jahr noch 100.000 abonnenten erreichen
und ich arbeite sehr hart dafür und
probiere ich jede woche aufs neue zu
unterhalten wenn ihr mich dabei haben
wollt dass ich dieses ziel erreiche und
ihr mich unterstützen wollt dass sich
die videos weiterhin so machen kann wie
ich sie mache mit so viel aufwand dann
lassen wir gerne an aber da und dann
schaffen wir das vielleicht wird euch
mit mir
wir sind da vastic tisch steht stabil da
der tisch aus glas wie so schreibe ich
eigentlich dass der tisch aus glas ist
das siehst du doch so johann kräftner
muss sterben und max muss auch verstehen
wie der phönix aus der asche hilfe ich
habe eine bockwurst inhalt reichen
wir müssen jetzt erstmal irgendwie rein
kommen ich habe schon gesehen dass vorne
leute stehen also security eine firma
von denen ich dachte dass sie daher sei
aber wegen kuranyi times müssen wir
jetzt erst einmal security vorbei und
diesen tisch mit reinnehmen mittlerweile
könnte man meinen dass ich geübt bin und
meinen stresslevel niedriger ist wenn
ich sachen irgendwann schmuggel weil ich
es eben schon
man könnte meinen dass mein stresslevel
mittlerweile ziemlich niedrig ist weil
ich schon des öfteren sachen ingo
reingeschmuggelt hat dem ist nicht so
ich fühle mich noch genau wie beim
ersten mal und hatte nicht das gefühl
dass man das vom stress level herr
besser wird na ja schrecklich kurz davor
einzugehen versehen und das funktioniert
das ist ziemlich beschissene weg für die
nächsten wochen habe ich ein ich hab
feldwerbung aufgehängt was komplett
jeglichen rahmen sprengen wird und was
dem absolut als folge video gerecht wird
[Musik]
besser heute nicht besser
wir sind jetzt auf der suche nach einem
platz wo es vernünftig hinstellen können
ein paar konsumgeile kunden auf unsere
tisch zu locken
diesem motto über angestellt aber
irgendwie scheint niemanden zu
interessieren
ich habe hier mein tisch hallo hallo da
haben wir dass ich gut machen mein gott
hier so ein schöner schöner glas tisch
mit an was erinnert doch bisschen auge
geworfen
die luft ist rein der kurs bis hin
umgebaut
wo ist das problem ja es ist wirklich
schön hier der passt aber nicht der
gehört hier hin dass tisch sieht jetzt
sehr passend aus hier gibt so viele
kleines herz stellt euch mal vor das
hier wäre so meinen sap um video zu
drehen
hallo freunde heute zeige ich euch wie
ihr dieses produkt in einen ikea
schmuggelt viel spaß
es fühlt sich an wie paradies im
gegensatz zu museum wo uns wirklich
absolut unangenehm war selbst kleinste
bewegungen zu machen den nicht mal
illegal gewesen sind hier habe ich das
schild und jetzt positionieren wir uns
ein paar meter entfernt und schauen ob
sich leute für den tisch interessiert
[Musik]
das stimmt schon der tisch casting sehr
schlecht in dieses zeitalter in dem raum
ist ja alles komplett dunkel und wann
sie will das lass ich mir ja bitte
ach ja mein gott oh mein gott oh mein
gott oh mein gott
umgekehrt funktioniert
oh mein gott
mein gott sie sind dann lachen haben
54 sie hat den zettel durchgelesen von
vorne befinden
wir warten jetzt hat man fucking halben
stunde und ist ein gar nichts mehr
passieren nicht mehr interessiert sich
für unsere tipps oder passt halt wie es
überhaupt nicht daran ich glaube es
gezeigt dass wir zum einen anderen punkt
finden und zum anderen jemanden wirklich
dazu bringen den tisch auch zu kaufen
haben muss denn heute wird nach außen
oder zumindest bis an die kasse damit
kommt das machten
wer bist du denn hier gelandet
ich habe hier wirklich absolut bei der
hand gefühlt ist das hier das paradies
beispiel also wenn ich wollte könnte ich
denn jetzt hier hinstellen und es würde
niemanden jucken
aber das machen wir nicht hallo ich
bringe meinen eigenen tisch mit in den
ikea ist das okay ja es war okay wenn
ich ganz ganz verrückt werden könnte ich
auch meinen tisch einfach so hier auf
den kühlschrank stellen und den auf
machen und anfangen zu tanzen
aber ich bin ja nicht verrückt deswegen
auf den kühlschrank und fangen nicht an
zu träumen aber es würde gehen
ich bin ich komplett er könnte den tisch
auch auf diesen anderen tisch darstellen
aber ich bin nicht haben mache ich das
mit gefüllter ballon formel 1 scheint
dieser schloss nicht einfach gekauft
[Musik]
weil die sonstigen mit mehrfacher
produkt interessiert hat gibt es selbst
für den unschlagbaren preis von 9 cent
handling abteil in dieser grabbelkiste
mit gekauft da stelle ich das jetzt
einfach ein und vielleicht schaffen ist
jemand mit bis zu kaufen und dann
wenigstens pro mein gott meine anfang an
stark schon wieder vom man sieht aber
fast so aus als wäre die luft rein um
mein gott oh mein gott
bring das produkt er nun zurück sei es
ja selber loben hierher geholt von hier
hat es das genau von hier komplett aber
natürlich hier so ein bisschen ein handy
und brachte mir auch dass jemand dafür
interessiert
2 34 stunden meines kauft niemand nimmt
sich dafür sind euro würde das bedeuten
dass ich als ich 50 euro dafür
ausgegeben habe deutlich zu viel bezahlt
haben oder dass die leute hier kein
geschmack an unseren beiden auf jeden
fall nicht weiter und ich warte und war
der hund war okay da kommt security
wir sind kann der hat schon einen blick
darauf geworfen jetzt auf dem rückweg
geht der safe noch mal vorbei und kommt
nochmal 100 prozent da ist jemand seit
fünf minuten und liest einfach dieses
ding alter der liest doch kompletten
ding sind haben sich wert hier verrückt
wirklich um das in diesen tisch nicht
genommen habe das sind power diehl und
niemand nimmt diesen pathetischer alter
alle tisch front tut sich rein gar nicht
und das sehr schlecht denn ich hatte mir
eigentlich vorgestellt dass jetzt gleich
irgendjemand kommt den mitnimmt und
werden riesen spektakel erleben aber wir
laufen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen weiter
herum und schauen in zehn minuten noch
mal da ist
filmer dahinter
er ist einfach weg die karosse mit
grüßen gucken kann welcher kasseler
steht die können eigentlich nicht so
weit gekommen sind
der größte los sie denn es gibt auf
diesem planeten alter ich warte eine
über eine stunde bis irgendjemand nimmt
ich gehe fünf minuten weg und ich werde
komplett ausgenommen hat er ja auch mein
gott
gibt es einen menschen der so los ist
wichtig und gibt es eine menschenmenge
hat kaspar von einer frauen direkt
angeguckt wird weil wir hier am film
sind brauch ich bin so fucking los die
zum einen habe ich gerade meine
lieblings tisch aus meinem zimmer
verloren zum anderen habe ich keine
aufnahme wie den jemen mitgenommen habe
ich habe keine ahnung oder ist ich habe
keine ahnung ob jetzt irgendjemand
körper damit an der kasse hat was der
ein was das eigentliche ziel des videos
war also ganz geschafft diesen tisch um
zu labeln wir haben's geschafft den hund
rein zu bringen und wir haben's
geschafft einfach zu verpacken und das
große finale nicht zu filmen war
megageil last ein like da kommentiert
irgendwas bis nächste woche ihre
absolute mega scheiße